I've been since November 4th.
November 3rd.
Now I don't even remember was the election
November 3rd or November 4th.
Since the early November presidential election,
we have covered the goalpost moves from the
right about when Trump is coming back to power.
And we are now hours from the next milestone.
And law enforcement is on alert over concerns
that the Kuhnen Trump and people may go nuts
when Donald Trump obviously does not become
president tomorrow.
I'll tell you about that conspiracy theory
in a moment.
As a reminder, I tell me if I'm missing anything,
but initially the claim was Donald Trump won
in early November.
And we will know that when all the votes are
counted, increasingly, as it seemed, that
was not the case.
The move was we are going to file lawsuits
in some places to stop the count, in some
places to keep counting.
Even though the ballots are all done being
counted, there's no more ballots to count.
And once that's done, Donald Trump will be
announced as the next president of the United
States.
November 8th came and the media said, we've
seen enough.
Clearly, Joe Biden is the winner at that point.
The Trump move became sometime between now
and December 14th when the electors actually
certify the state elections and vote their
electoral votes.
We will get these results overturned either
through lawsuits or through sending a different
slate of electors or whatever.
And none of that happened.
Then on December 14th, Joe Biden got his three
hundred and six electoral votes.
And then they said between December 14th and
January 6th, the formal counting and acceptance
of the electoral votes in a joint session
of the House and Senate sometime in that three
and a half week period for a three week period,
they are going to do something which will
prevent Joe Biden from officially getting
those votes on January 6th.
Then we know how that turned out.
And then they were waiting for something to
happen between January 6th and January 20th,
and that didn't happen.
So the new one is March 4th, which is tomorrow.
There are segments of Q and on Trump, people
who believe that tomorrow, March 4th, Donald
Trump will become president again.
Why?
Because the presidential inauguration up until
1933 was on March 4th instead of January 20th,
1933.
That was changed and Inauguration Day became
January 20th.
And the belief they have is that Donald Trump
is going to make a defiant and triumphant
return to the Oval Office tomorrow.
Now, of course, it's not going to happen,
but authorities and law enforcement are worried
and will be on high alert for tomorrow because
the chance of violence is non-zero.
Now, they are saying it doesn't seem as though
there's a major risk of violence tomorrow
when Donald Trump obviously does not become
president of the United States.
Law enforcement saying they're not seeing
large scale physical mobilization.
That suggests there will be in-person events,
that a lot of it is online.
And for the time being, we are being told
that law enforcement is on alert, but not
expecting major violence or in-person elements.
Capitol Police, of course, is monitoring it.
Federal authorities are exercising caution,
et cetera.
There will be additional personnel deployed
around the Capitol building.
National Guard is going to continue supporting
local officers in Washington, D.C. and members
of Congress who are willing to accept that
this is another conspiracy, a conspiracy theory
that's floating around are remaining vigilant,
I guess, is what we are going to say.
Is this the end, in all honesty?
Is this the end of these wild conspiracy theories
that Donald Trump is going to take power back
over?
And in a sense, I think there will never be
an end.
And what I mean by that is as follows.
When Trump doesn't become president tomorrow,
they might move on to some new date.
Joe Biden will never make it past June one
or something like that.
Eventually, the date will just become the
20 24 election that that's that's my belief
at this point in time as these milestone dates
come and go, much like with these end timers
who they make a prediction and then the world
doesn't end.
And then they say, well, we you know, our
protractor was not aligned properly and we
miscalculated.
It's actually going to be this other thing,
this other thing, this other thing.
Eventually they'll just go go to we are taking
power back in November of twenty, twenty four
when Donald Trump will win.
So if you're expecting them to ever say it's
really over, I doubt they're going to do that.
I think it will just move to the 2024 election
and as an intermediate, probably even the
20 22 election where they will claim they're
going to take control of the House and Senate,
which they may, which is why it's important
for us to be more focused on the midterms
rather than on 2024 at this point in time.
A little homework for you, if you're willing.
If you're interested, keep an eye out for
what they say tomorrow when Trump doesn't
become president.
Send me examples of how they rationalize it
or what they're saying.
If you're on parler, maybe you can find some
interesting stuff there.
Right wing news websites coping, Magga, Twitter,
as it's called subheadings.
I'm curious and maybe we'll make a segment
out of it